motions Run High for nymphal Perez
whenever she's reminded of the two years
their family home had no power
it was so dark my baby Wella almost got
stepped on
since then she swore she would never
miss a payment
but electricity prices in the
Philippines are some of the most
expensive in Asia and it remains a
struggle for nympha so total
electrification president Ferdinand
Marcos JR says he's aware of this burden
and looming energy shortage and is open
to all solutions including nuclear
this nuclear power plant was
commissioned in the 1970s by his father
it was intended to power millions of
homes but was never used
there have been efforts to get the
Bataan Nuclear Power Plant up and
running before that right behind me is a
plant's reactor but now under the
leadership of President Ferdinand Marcos
Jr there's more optimism than ever
question is whether the project is still
viable after being dormant for decades
nuclear energy Advocate and Congressman
Marco juanco has been lobbying for
Bataan for years he believes that with a
little work it could be as good as new
South Korean company has offered to
rehabilitate it for a billion dollars
my precedent which is uh watch bar 2
nuclear plant in Tennessee and it was
not used for decades because the
Electric market never materialized and
in 2009 they decided to commission the
plant
but batan has been settled by corruption
allegations critics also argue the
safety concerns that led to the decision
to shut it down have not been addressed
it's near to the Manila Luzon French
fault lines there was Chernobyl and
there was a Fukushima we thought that
the Bataan Nuclear Power Plant will
never come back
president Marcos is exploring other
Energy Solutions while in a working
visit to the U.S Capitol in Maine he met
Executives of a company selling
micronuclear fuel technology and
recently extended the contract for
natural gas drilling off the west coast
of the Philippines
nympha says she understands very little
about these debates but knows for sure
that what she wants and needs is
Affordable electricity
Barn below Al Jazeera Bataan the
Philippines